vielen dank wir haben ja vor ungefähr
einem monat eine bundestagswahl gehabt
diese woche hat sich sogar der deutsche
bundestag konstituiert zu einer
bundeswahl gehört natürlich zu einer
bundestagswahl gehört natürlich auch
eine sachliche analyse der wahl und
genau da ist mein punkt ich bei dieser
wahl hat man festgestellt dass gerade
die fdp bei den sogenannten erstwählern
besonders stark und besonders gut
abgeschnitten hat und mich stört bei der
aktuellen debatte dass immer wieder
akteure gibt die versuchen dieses
ergebnis diese gerade für diese gruppe
schlecht zu reden ich finde das ist
gerade in einer demokratie
äußerst problematisch wenn man die
entscheidung die bewusste
wahlentscheidung von jungen menschen
oder allgemein einer wahl gruppe
hinterher so schlecht redet und vater
haben in frage gestellt und darüber muss
man reden
genau also ich stelle mir das vollkommen
zu und da sind wir wieder bei den
problemen dass wir eben angesprochen
haben oder also es gibt ja eine
gesellschaftliche erwartung an junge
menschen dass sie links sein müssen das
gehört irgendwie zum guten ton und man
muss gegen das system sein man muss für
eine grüne ökologische umwelt sein und
wenn dann bei einer wahl dann doch
heraus kommt oh mein gott ganz schön
viele haben fdp gewählt und sind eben
doch nicht so gegen das system sondern
fügen sich da gerne allen und denken
sich vielleicht auch ich leistung lohnt
sich der saal was die fdp eben filiale
hat dann muss man das draufhauen dann
darf das auf jeden fall nicht sein dann
muss man das thema tier sind aus dem
diskurs rausschmeißen das ist halt was
sie jetzt eben also diese zdf-sendung
haben sie erwähnt diese frau das ist
halt einfach antidemokratisch
demokratisch es ja schon wenn man im
in deutschland oder sonst wo seine
meinung sagen darf und auch vorkommt
kann ja sagen was sie will im endeffekt
dass sie nicht als grüne vertreterin der
grünen happy ist das so für die jungen
menschen fdp gewählt haben und im
ausdruck gibt wie seine politische
meinungsäußerung ist ja christian
thielemann ja ich gut finde es nicht
antidemokratische wenn man sagt ist ja
unglaublich dass so viele junge menschen
fdp gewählt haben weil man sich nun bei
ärgert dass sie nicht die grünen gewählt
haben aber ich wollte eigentlich auch
was anderes hinaus ich fand sie ein
bisschen es war natürlich toll dass
jemand besitzt als urgestein der fdp
gerhart baum der ja eher vom linken
flügel der fdp kam und kommt immer noch
und das der auf einmal den
leistungsgedanken
gegenüber magath verteidigt also es
nachher der leistungsgedanke haben sie
etwa nichts damit zu tun und dass der
mit 89 ist ja toll doch völlig
beieinander der sitz aber dass da keiner
von fdp sonst sitzt sowieso fehlt mir
das auch fällt mir das auf jetzt gerade
sie sind hier das ist wunderbar aber so
nicht von bissing oder christian lindner
hat also man sieht scholz man sieht
habeck aber die halten sich ja wirklich
sehr sehr bedeckt
muss nicht so ein bisschen mehr erklärt
werden was die fdp vor hat was sie will
auch auf angriffe reagieren
und nicht nur und 89 jährigen bei allem
respekt urgestein da den
leistungsgedanken für die fdp erklären
also er war ja nun mal eingeladen
dagegen kann nichts machen ist also eine
freie entscheidung an ich bin übrigens
auch heute hier weil ich eingeladen
wurde ist ja nicht so dass ich einfach
hier hingekommen bin mich hingesetzt und
ja weil ich neulich glaube vor zwei
wochen waren bei einem sendungen im
fernsehen wo sehr konkret abends eine
sehr bekannte sendung sehr konkret über
die künftige koalition gesprochen wurde
wurde über die ampelkoalition gesprochen
wurde und vor allem über die fdp
gesprochen wurde und da war in der
sendung herr scholz und er habe und sie
sprachen über die fdp reine gleich
vertreter der fdp war eingeladen fand
ich bin mir eigentlich war kein
vertreter der fdp eingeladen fand ich
auch bemerkenswert auf der anderen seite
ich saß vor dem fernseher hat mir das
angeguckt da dachte ich mensch was muss
die fdp für eine wichtige politische
kraft in diesem land sein dass diese
zwei gestalten oder personen gerade nur
über diese fdp reden obwohl sie gar
nicht dabei ist also von daher kann man
so von der seite ist okay ich dachte
werden eingeladen gewesen war nicht da
aber und dann haben sie gelernt hast
schon erstaunlich ehrlich gesagt das vom
künftigen koalitionspartner man darf ja
mal für sie fröhlich optimistisch sein
so ein aussage kommt also ich meine die
grüne will jetzt mit der fdp und der spd
irgendwie zusammen polieren und dann
hört man dass die wahl der scp ein
skandal ist also ich mag mir nur
vorstellen aber es ist ja nicht nur es
ist ja nicht nur dieser fall gewesen ich
habe schon einige kommentatoren zu
diesem thema in den letzten tagen wochen
gehört die übrigen es war immer ihr
verordneten genau genau und es war immer
so so ein unterton dabei mensch dieser
junge leute die die fdp gewählt haben
verantwortungslos und politik kein
verständnis für die pandemische lage
also da waren immer diese beschreibung
mit dabei und und das hat mich immer
dass also das stört einem egal was diese
leute letztendlich gewählt haben man
muss das in einer demokratie
respektieren und so kommentiert man
nicht wollen
das stört sie zu recht wenn ich weil ich
meine es gibt viele junge menschen die
die fdp aus ganz besonderen gründen
gewählt haben sind freiheitsliebend sie
sind unheimlich interessiert sind
fortschritts gläubig sind auch digitale
eingestellt und gefällt was die fdp da
anzubieten hat auch in dem wahlprogramm
ich glaube auch im netzauftritt und in
dem wahlkampf das hat viele angesprochen
und deswegen möchten viele menschen da
auch sich sich irgendwie vielleicht
nicht zu hause fühlen aber sich
zumindest dem annähernd und haben ihnen
die stimme gegeben aber ich gebe ihnen
noch eine andere sache ich müsste das
heute wieder aufgefallen dass gibt seine
kampagne jetzt gegen christian lindner
als finanzminister das fing an mit einem
stieglitz das geht heute weiter wo man
irgendwelche startup leute gefunden hat
in berlin die sagen habe wird auch der
richtig weil der uns versteht glaube die
haben sich alle nicht angeguckt was der
geschrieben hat im grünen programm was
gewinnausschüttung und den verbleib von
gewinnen in der unternehmen angeht das
ist bei nach dem programm bei vielen
stars nämlich ganz düster aus also das
wundert mich ein bisschen dass hier die
vereinte der medienmacht von bestimmter
seiten und anfängt zu versuchen
christian gentner als finanzminister von
dem ich wirklich ausgesprochen positiv
beeindruckt bin in den letzten wochen
eher als finanzminister zu demontieren
ich finde das ist es ist einfach unklug
und wäre sicherlich ein hervorragender
finanzminister für unser land ich finde
solche kampagnen übrigens sowieso ein
unding solche verhinderungs kampagnen
also es gehört sich einfach nicht jetzt
war die kritik groß anderen jungen
bildern der fdp jetzt ist doch viel
spannender was liefert nun die fdp
leuten also wenn ich mir das renten
programm anschauen
also ich nicht aber ich persönlich waren
nicht überrascht dass so viele
erstwähler die fdp gewählt haben man
sieht dass bei uns schon auf kreisebene
bei den kreisverbänden was für
neumitglieder zu fdp kommen und das ist
immer sehr spannend diese entwicklung
die sind mal es gibt phasen die sind
unterschiedlich aber ich habe schon in
den letzten
zwei bis drei jahren eine beobachtung
gemacht gerade auf kommunaler ebene auf
lokaler ebene das ausserordentlich viele
junge menschen zu uns kommen sie
interessieren sich für klimaschutz
die interessieren sich für leistung die
interessieren sich für ihre zukunft die
interessieren sich für fragen wie rente
ich habe solche als junger mensch
eigentlich mich für das thema rente
überhaupt nicht interessiert aber
bemerkenswert diese leute schon
und vor allem was noch also was die sind
überwiegend männlich das ernst man
leider dazu sagen was heißt leider aber
es ist nun ist ja gerade nun
analyse und viele von denen sind
christian linder als typ einfach gut und
hat höre ich oft bei den erstgesprächen
was ist die hauptmotivation zur fdp zu
kommen rosalinda aber da habe ich
vielleicht meine frage nicht richtig
gestellt sondern
jetzt haben sie so viele junge stimmen
bekommen und mich würde es interessieren
in den koalitionsgesprächen muss ja auch
teil sind was kriegen die jetzt kann die
junge politik also das ist ein
unglaublich sympathischer und cleverer
schafft
quasi hier eine falle zu stellen aus den
gesprächen zu bilanz um die
wünsche mir dass ihr euch bei der rente
durchsetzt weil ihr die einzigen seit
die irgendwie ein halbwegs vernünftiges
konzept hat das kein ausverkauf an der
jungen generation ist und insofern
ist ein bisschen schwach auf der brust
das rentenkonzept hat natürlich die cdu
vorgelegt das ist klar aber die man mir
schon wünschen dass sich dann natürlich
die fdp durchsetzt ja also es gibt ja es
gibt ja schon ein sanierungs papier das
ja kein anderes was ich hier verrate und
da ist ja daraus kann man auch entnehmen
dass das team das dieses thema also
einer der wichtigen themen besonders
wichtigen themen ist und dass in dem
zusammenhang und das ist ja jetzt auch
nichts neues was ich erzähle dass die
fdp von diesem aktien modell also von
diesem aus system von dieser
systemkomponente auch in den letzten
jahren gesprochen hat ist auch nichts
neues und das ist mit in diesem
sondierungs papier drin und
dementsprechend werden die die
zuständigen fachgruppen ja natürlich
gemeinsam alles tun damit so ein modell
am ende des tages steht aber ich bin
nicht in dieser gruppe und ich bin in
einer anderen gruppe aber ich werde
trotzdem nichts über diese gruppen das
heißt auch gepasst und sortierung papier
steht ist aus der spur wenig ungerecht
wirkungsorientierte beim thema rente zu
handeln warten wir doch bislang habe
also ist es dauert ja nicht mehr lange
und dann liegen die ersten ergebnisse
vor und dann können wir noch mal in
einer sendung dann darüber diskutieren
aber warten wir erst mal